les questions on vous trouve l'info
plusieurs bouteilles de lotion indiquent
que leur produit est testé reconnu
recommandé conçu éprouvée par des
dermatologues
on nous a demandé est ce vrai les
dermatologues ont-ils le top d'approuver
tous ces produits
nous avons posé la question testé par
signifie que un test a été fait par
lieberman pour prouver que le produit ne
provoque pas d'irritation recommandé par
dans le cas de avis nous signifie plutôt
que l'entreprise a fait des sondages
auprès des dermatologues tandis que
conçu par signifie que des dermatologues
ont collaboré à la mise au point du bris
derme
toutes ces mentions sont faites par les
entreprises elles-mêmes
il faut donc les croire sur parole par
contre cette mention est différente
plusieurs fabricants payent
l'association canadienne des
dermatologues pour réviser leurs données
c'est le cas du groupe marcel si leurs
produits respectent les critères de
l'association ils ont droit ou logo
mais dites vous que les fabricants ne
peuvent pas créer mais trop épais la loi
sur la concurrence interdit des
indications trompeuses facilement
[Musique]